it's great to welcome back to the
program after a couple of years I
believe Chris Martenson who is of course
the co-founder of pre peak prosperity
dot-com he speaks all over the world one
of the early econo bloggers serves on
all sorts of panels including un panels
Chris it's great to have you back i was
checking out some of the commentaries
you recently put out on peak prosperity
dot-com and you had an interesting
discussion about how when we talk about
crises not all crises are equal some
have very clear fixes some don't and
this got me thinking about discussions
about employment and labor in the
economy in this presidential campaign
that we have now and I've noticed that
missing from the discussions about who's
going to be better for jobs or worse for
jobs who's going to reinvigorate
manufacturing or the economy or whatever
missing are to sort of important ideas
one is that many of the manufacturing
jobs that at one point did go overseas
no longer exist and they don't exist to
be brought back to the US and number two
and it's related the idea that
automation as a job Eliminator also
isn't destroyed by presidential
candidates so I want to open it up to
you first generally when you talk about
not all crisis crises being equal what
are you referring to and how does this
relate to the presidential election well
David good to be back with you and your
listeners and this is this important
topic and it's distinguished like this
we have to distinguish between problems
and predicaments now a problem has a
solution we can derive one and usually
politicians like to focus on the problem
side because there's something that can
be done even if that doesn't make a lot
of sense but there's something you can
propose a predicament doesn't have a
solution it just has an outcome that you
have to manage so Japan has a rapidly
aging population they're losing
population on a net basis and what's
remaining is aging quickly as I just
said so that's a predicament that really
you have to manage that and so there are
a lot of things were
basing now that our predicaments in our
politicians are talking about them
because they don't see a win so they
avoid them but we don't get to avoid
them because they're still with us so
along the lines of the the job
automation side my analysis has been
Hillary Clinton nor Donald Trump have
any interest in bringing that up because
if they are the first to the other will
say look at that my opponent is
basically just admitting we're going to
lose jobs yeah yeah yeah it's because of
Technology sure but that is that is a a
loss and it is a point of being able to
be attacked and and so in is that a
sense in which in our example about job
automation there's really no political
advantage to being up front and saying
hey everybody there's a bigger picture
predicament to use your vocabulary that
we need to think about when we look at
unemployment or stimulus or whatever
else it might be that's absolutely
correct so let's look at a couple of
examples we know that there are 260,000
robots operating in the United States
right now and the number is growing
exponentially as we're speaking and some
of these are pretty obvious people say
oh well we can see how this robot is now
welding seams in a car plant so we don't
need the welder the human welder in that
car plant I see how that job got taken
away but we're all the way down to the
point now where they're having robots
essentially take the orders in
McDonald's and other pieces of
automation which are doing away with the
human component of labor and this is a
trend it's going on it's going to
continue to accelerate because you know
humans are expensive relatively speaking
and because business in America is now
all about just making money it's always
about the profits it's about your
profits there's no more sense of greater
duty that Henry Ford said you know way
back at the turn of the last century
where he said if I pay my workers enough
to afford my cars i win that seems to be
missing from the dialogue neither party
seems to be interested in actually
talking about that but the predicament
remains and if they were daring enough
they would a mention that it happens and
then be say here's what we need to
understand we have to engage in this
world in
new way and we're going to have to try
some new things they would have to be
bold they would have to display real
leadership and they would have to be
willing to risk a few corporate dollars
in their in their campaign coffers to
make those statements I want to get to
the engaging with the world in a new way
because this is something we've been
talking about a lot but before we get to
that for our audience what are some of
the other bigger picture predicaments
that you've identified that are going to
sort of shape the the picture of society
and economies going forward great
question this is my passion it's my work
it's everything I focus on at peak
prosperity i've spent about 10 years on
this i'll spend the next 20 years if I'm
alive that long or however long I've got
this is what I want to focus on we're
facing predicaments and large-scale
future trends not just in jobs and
automation but ecologically with respect
to our energy and energy sources and
economically and in particular the
explosive rise of debt globally all over
the world these are all gigantic
predicaments that we absolutely need to
face square up because our leaders
aren't facing them to head on or head on
that's why I do what I do I'm here to
first educate people about what the
context is and then when people go well
that's a big story what do I do it's
about the solutions that we can all
engage in on a personal level that makes
sense given the larger context and oh by
the way if we all did these steps that I
recommend I think we'd be making the
world a better place and we'd be
creating a world worth inheriting
there's lots we can do but we're not
doing at the National global level so
guess what that means it's it's up to us
to do these things can you talk a little
bit about the difference between when
you talk about debt more broadly as a
global predicament because we we've
discussed quite a bit how but typically
Republican politicians using quote
paying down the debt as a way to improve
the economy is not really backed up by
most serious economic analyses but
that's sort of at the micro country
political solution level can you talk
about how that's different than what
you're saying with
guard to global debt absolutely and this
is a critical distinction let me draw up
this way when the crisis began in 2007
we had about a hundred I'm rounding
numbers here we had about a hundred and
fifty trillion dollars in debt
outstanding worldwide now this is just
debt this isn't unfunded liabilities
like Social Security being underfunded
or pensions just debt and since 2007 to
the end of 2014 that dead exploded by
fifty seven trillion dollars were over
200 trillion dollars in debt worldwide
now here's the thing about debt that's
not being talked about at the micro or
even the macro level where it really
needs to what is 200 trillion dollars in
debt really saying to us I know it's a
big number I can't even think of how big
it is but 200 trillion is saying we need
the future to be bigger than the present
by bigger we mean more car sold more
economic output and activity more
throughput of resources we need more
from the world we have to shove it
through our economic machine just so we
can pay back that 200 trillion but the
entire banking system says 200 trillion
we need that to be 220 and then 240 and
then eventually 300 trillion because
that's the model it's always based on
growth so I mentioned ecology a little
while ago I'm one of those guys who says
hey hold on the earth is a sphere then
he has a finite volume it has a fixed
limit and we're acting politically and
economically as if no limits exist but
our generation the people alive
listening to this right now are alive at
a time when humans as a species are
running up against hard limits and we
can see them fisheries collapsing
insects and other species disappearing
at alarming rates the 2016 every month
being the hottest one on record these
are all signs that Satan yeah there's
some real actual limits here they have
nothing to do with how much money or
debts in the system debt is a claim on
real stuff real stuff isn't fixed supply
that's the battle over the next 5 10 20
maybe forever number of years and very
few people are looking at this in a
really large level but it's happening
and people listening to this will
already know it's happening if they open
the newspaper and just read so we're
talking about a planet that is a finite
size and resources we're
talking about a significant change to
labor in that previously new
technologies actually expanded the
number of jobs available by creating new
industries and now most of what i would
consider sensible estimates say now
technology is actually net eliminating
jobs what do you see as the sort of
changing relationship between humans and
our existence on the planet and at the
sort of political level one of the
things I keep going back to is should we
be thinking about some kind of basic
income that dis aggregates someone's job
and daily activities from some basic
ability to live on this planet is that
something that is interesting to you
what what else are you thinking about
David those and many other things which
we could put in a bucket called non
status quo solutions so before I dive
into a couple those here's where I think
the battle is going to be won or lost
it's in the narratives we run now humans
for about if this is the entire human
history written word came in right at
the very end otherwise it was all this
oral tradition we're used to stories and
narratives and they run our lives we're
aware of this on a daily individual
basis right the story I have in my head
makes me either experience joy or
suffering the stories drive our
behaviors so we have a cultural story
that's wrong and that cultural story is
growth is good now it has been for a
long time but it's no longer serving us
because that growth when it runs into
limits tends to break on the shores that
it rams into without noticing there
there so here's the positive side of the
story I visited the farms that are
building topsoil at incredible rates
where if everybody did that we would
take more carbon out of the atmosphere
in ten years than has been put in
through all of human existence but we're
not farming that way we're farming a
different way which is actually we're
doing the opposite of that putting
carbon into the atmosphere the
difference between the the positive
story in the current story we're running
is the narrative and the narrative says
oh making money is the most important
thing and that's why this is the best
way to farm so let's keep doing that we
have to change that narrative and says
no we're not here to just make money
we're here to enjoy our time on on the
planet and leave it as good or better
for the next everything's not just
humans that follow because we're part of
a overall system so if I had to break
the narrative down we have a narrative
of growth it's based on this idea of
extraction and it's very isolated we
isolate from each other and also from
the natural world and instead we need a
different narrative that's more
regenerative and it's relational and we
have the technologies in place already
that can do that if better ones come
along super but we don't need them if we
had a different narrative today we could
be putting our money and our resources
towards things that actually matter you
know that old model of we're going to
squabble over resources and fight deadly
wars when we don't get our way those
need to be replaced with a more global
sense of this is kind of an emergency we
really have to figure out a lot of
things all at once we're going to have
to shift our cultural political and
economic institutions it a pace that's
never been done in human history it's an
awesome challenge I i I'm actually
excited by it but if and only if we have
the right story running and the right
story has to be were stewards not
consumers if that's not too broad of a
shift real quick just in the last few
seconds we have on the basic income
thing interesting idea given where
things are going thinking too small not
practical what do you think it's an
interesting idea but incentives are
everything to humans a lot of humans
given the incentive of not having to
work won't work and I'm a big believer
that if a basic income can make sense
but it needs to be tied to something
where everybody has a sense of
investment in this common experiment
that we're all running together so
there's ways I think it could be done
well in other ways it could be done
poorly it's a very complex question
we'll have to have you back as all the
studies I've seen suggest that most
people even given a basic income would
still work they might just work in
something they actually like as opposed
to what they are sort of stuck in by the
very nature of our of our society but a
conversation for a different day Chris
Martenson co-founder of peak prosperity
dot com of course check out his
infamous crash course Chris it's so
great to talk to you as always thank you
David pleasures been mine